descendants three is airing in August
2019 and we are so pumped there are a
ton of fan theories out there about what
will go down in the final movie of the
franchise keep watching to find out what
the tarot cards at the end of every
descendent 3 trailer actually mean all
about Hades Disney's descendants first
dropped a teaser called is it Hades
where we find out that Hades is a cool
rock and roll guitar playing God and we
also find out that he's trying to escape
the Isle of the laws he doesn't think he
belongs there at all because he's a god
there's a flash of him fighting a dragon
on what looks like a ship is the dragon
mouth or is it her mom then someone
sneaks up on him while he's playing
guitar and he tells them that they
shouldn't have come here you shouldn't
have come spend the teaser ends and we
see a card with Emma's face on it
the following week Disney Channel
dropped another Hades trailer this is
huge because it's too full teaser
trailers about the theme new character
Hades talks about how awful it would be
if auradon was under attack and we see a
clip of king Adam and fairy godmother
looking absolutely terrified Hades is
really upset about the Isle of the Lost
he thinks it's messed up that bellum
beast decided who was good and evil he
says there is only a matter of time
before you can stay on the Isle without
going mad
Katie's definitely gets arrested at some
point and has marched through the halls
of the castle he's determined to take
over auradon and the only thing standing
in his way are the V K's he thinks they
have betrayed their people he's
hell-bent on revenge the trailer ends
and we see another umma card we also
know that one of the big threats to
auradon is a sleeping spell and that
some people are getting turned to stone
we also find out that the only thing
more powerful than maleficent scepter is
Hades ember and it's hinted in the
mystery trailer that Hades might have
the ability to drain other people's
powers the ember will be the key to
mousey the auradon now that we know all
about Hades let's take a look at these
fan theories Hades doesn't know mal is
his daughter
it's pretty much been established that
mouths mystery father as Hades in the
very first teaser for descendants 3 now
is
Dean walking toward a blue fire and now
we know that Hades can literally make
himself burn with the same blue flames
Mao says dad when she reaches it now ad
seems pretty villainous and honestly who
can blame him he spent most of his life
as the god of the underworld according
to Greek mythology he didn't really have
a choice in the matter and it's hard to
be a really good guy when you have to
deal with people's souls then he gets
trapped on the Isle of the Lost yes to
live literally underground instead of
the underworld and to make matters worse
there's no magic on the Isle but oddly
enough we later see him erupted into
blue flames while in his lair does he
actually have some magic is he a God
after all could fairy godmother really
have gotten rid of all of his powers we
also hear him complaining about the vks
they stand in his way and he thinks that
they have turned their backs on their
roots but we aren't so sure that Hades
would say that about his daughter he
seems pretty vicious about the vks we
just find it hard to believe that he
would insult his daughter like that and
we aren't the only ones who think so
fans have pointed this out that leads us
to think one thing hades doesn't know
mal is his daughter think about it
what if Maleficent never told him about
their daughter she could have raised mal
all by herself her mouth entire life she
also told mal that her father was human
either Maleficent didn't know that Hades
was a god or she didn't want mal to know
there could be a lot of reasons for this
maybe she wanted to protect mal or maybe
she didn't want now to think her father
was better than her that seems like a
pretty Maleficent way to think about
things we think that not only will now
discover her father but her father will
also discover her how will that change
things
well Hades turned good at the end
yeah uma and mal are sisters
uma told us in descendants too that that
wasn't the end of her story you didn't
think this was the end of the story
did you we knew she would come back
somehow and Disney has told us that uma
is one of the enemies in descendant 3
the plot that Disney Channel released
says that now must leave the island
auradon from Hades and uma there are
lots of theories that uma is working
with Hades and that seems to make a lot
of sense luma is incredibly powerful and
she wants revenge as much as Hades does
some people think that when Hades is
narrating the trailer he's actually
talking to uma but why would haiti's
align himself with her she's still just
a kid there have to be other villains
that would make better allies but what
if Ouma is his daughter too you would
definitely want to align himself with a
daughter and a god having a baby with a
sea which doesn't seem that unreasonable
but if Hades is the father of uma and
mal that makes the two enemies sisters
it would be half sisters and we kind of
love this theory it makes sense bloom
and mal used to be best friends they had
a huge bond until mal embarrassed uma
still they have a lot in common
they're both powerful and they're both
able to basically control the aisle mal
does it before she goes to auradon and
as soon as she's gone uma takes control
they're great leaders and they're both
really smart being half sisters would
complicate their relationship even more
but it would definitely tie up the
ending nicely if human Hades turned good
like mal did she could finally have the
loving family she deserves the real
villain Disney has been saying that
human Hades are the main villains in
descendant 3 and mal definitely thinks
that's the case but what if the real
villain is someone else entirely of
course there are theories that Audrey is
the real bad guy she does go evil for at
least a little while but we also know
that we're meeting another Disney
villain in this movie we're meeting dr.
facili a he was the boudu witch doctor
from Princess and the Frog and he's
seriously evil while Hades and uma have
reasons for being bad the doctor is just
a true bad guy
his motivations are pure evil we
wouldn't be surprised if Disney is just
trying to get us off of his trail we may
think we have the whole thing figured
out with Hades and uma but Disney
Channel wouldn't give us too much
information so why do we think the real
villain is dr. facili eh
the clues are all in the trailers dr.
Vasily a has a daughter named Celia and
from the trailers it looks like she's
one of the BK's who gets to go to
auradon prep but what if she goes to
help her father take over it would be
pretty similar two mouths mission in the
first movie we love when things come
full circle in the mystery trailer we
see the guards fighting some unknown
threat but if you look in the background
you can see Celia why is she just
hanging out there if there was a fight
most children would run but she looks
like she's watching over the situation
and we think she's holding a cat what
does that mean Celia is also seen
earlier in the trailer looking pretty
sinister while someone is narrating
about great evil she looks sketchy when
she unlocked some big door and she
laughs maniacally at some point good
people don't laugh like that this evil
will make all aboard on pay in the meat
Hades trailer we get a glimpse of dr.
faciliate
but if you look closely you can see mal
in the background is mal confronting him
then there are the cards every trailer
ends with a tarot card these cards
aren't used by gods and sea witches but
they are used by voodoo practitioners
that is a huge sign that dr. facili a is
a big deal we think Disney is dropping
real subtle clues that dr. faciliate and
Celia are way more important than we
think people get turned into villains we
know that there's a sleeping spell that
hits auradon and except cepting lots of
people and they don't know how to stop
it
but it also seems like some people are
getting turned into bad guys let's not
forget that King Adam was originally a
villain he was the Beast and he was
turned into the Beast because he had a
cruel heart of course he turned good
with the help of Belle I didn't make a
good decision till I was at least 42 you
decided to marry me at 28 it looks like
he gets turned back into the beast
during descendant 3 we see a beast
dressed like him in the woods he's
growling
and looks ready to fight what could turn
him back into a beast it would have to
be some pretty strong magic while
Maleficent scepter is stolen and Hades
ember is really powerful plus dr. facili
a is a witch doctor
they are all super powerful enemies then
there's Audrey months ago Disney
released a photo of Audrey it displayed
her looking like a villain and carrying
Maleficent staff she was in the woods
with Chad who looked terrified people
have thought for a long time that Audrey
isn't really a villain they think she
might end up being possessed and from
the latest trailers we think this makes
some sense when the sleeping spell hits
auradon she looks totally shocked and
she's not dressed like a villain at all
then we see that audrey falls victim to
the sleeping spell she's asleep in her
bed
hades is there casting some sort of
magic with his ember is he waking her up
or is he possessing her we have no idea
but these latest trailers make it look
like Audrey isn't really bad we think
the theories that she's under a villain
making spell makes total sense but who
possesses her she definitely has the
scepter at some point and we know that
the scepter gets stolen along with the
Queen's crown the Queen's crown has blue
gems that looks like Hades amber does
someone use Audrey to steal these things
from the museum or does she steal them
from another villain we have so many
questions we kind of hope Audrey isn't
really evil
she might be mean but if she really a
villain the clues are in the cards we
already talked about the tarot cards
being a sign that dr. facili a is the
real villain but there's a lot more to
the cards than you might think there are
actually clues to the next big teaser
trailer at the end of every trailer a
boudu card flies over the screen it says
different things related to descendants
on it let's take a look at all of them
after we see a card form out we get a
trailer of mouths vision the card at the
end of the teaser says ordered on the
next trailer shows the sleeping spell
the trailer has a card for Hades at the
end of it we get two trailers for Hades
next both of these have a card for uma
that means there's a really good chance
our next trailer will have a lot to do
with uma and we cannot wait to figure
out more about her role we know that the
showdown between
mal will be epic and we want to know if
she's really working with Hades what
card do you think will be at the end of
Emma's trailer we would be happy if we
found out more about Audrey doctor
facili a or Celia descendants three is
set to premiere sometime in August 2019
and we cannot wait
we hope Disney Channel keeps dropping
some clues about the movie what do you
think will happen in the final film of
the franchise give this video a big
thumbs up and then tell us your theories
in the comments section below thanks for
watching if you love all things Disney
hit that subscribe button for more
awesome videos from the things see you
next time
[Music]